war das purer zufall dass sie auf den
delfinen gestoßen sind oder waren sie
auf der suche nach ihm
nee das war tatsächlich zufall also mein
vater und ich sind öfter unterwegs
zusammen und haben ihn dann schon etwas
weiter gesehen die finde da kam uns dann
auch schon entgegen und dann haben wir
die begegnung gehabt quasi jetzt haben
wir gerade ja schon die bilder gesehen
die ihr vater aufgenommen hat wie lange
konnten sie dann mit dem delfin
schwimmen
das schätzen es ziemlich schwer weil der
moment einfach so magisch war sage ich
mal aber ich denke das war so zu
dreiviertel stunde auf jeden fall haben
sie auch gerade gesagt sie sind da ja
öfter in der gegend unterwegs sehr der
film wurde auch schon einige male dort
gesichtet denken sie dass es noch einmal
zu einem zweiten treffen kommen wird ich
will es hoffen also bei mir auf jeden
fall an der bx auch wünschen aber so
genau sagen kann man es natürlich nicht
und weiß ja auch nicht ob das einmalig
war oder ob er öfter lust darauf hat und
sich menschen näher das kann man nicht
sagen
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur weil
die schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren